you hear that
exactly
today is tyka's
first day at school
and we finally have some peace and quiet
to get some work done don't get me wrong
i love it when he's around i love him to
death i love spending every minute with
him because he's so freaking fun and we
play and we have a really good time but
when he's around it's tough to get work
done and if work doesn't get done bills
don't get paid
and we're not going to be able to
have food and and have all the fun toys
that he likes
but what i'm also really excited and
looking forward to
is ma bear
cleaned her side of the office yesterday
if you guys watched that vlog but she
organized it all and so now i get
you scared me
but now can i really yeah i get my
what is it a co-worker back
yeah i get my co-worker back yep and i
come bearing gifts
oh hell yeah
my dad came um the other day
um and he has these oranges that he
that grows grows in his house
and they're so freaking sweet
i think he pees on the soil you know
what i mean like i feel like
the only way to achieve this type of
sweetness is to add some type of
fertilizer
he doesn't get fertilizer that i've seen
besides uh old
tyson's poop
and pee he actually shits in the floor
you're dead yeah is the cat in his way
yep
that's where you get it from yeah no no
i think honestly the the floor is so
fertilized because of tyson needs to
live with my dad
and he would pee and poop my dad has a
small
backyard you know german shepherds
got big old poops so i think it's very
well concentrated there
but those things are sweet huh
not as sweet as me but they're close
shut up lunch break time
left the vlog camera upstairs not to run
upstairs to get it that's what i'm out
of breath
it was cuny
damn
hey i lost three pounds
[Applause]
thank you i appreciate that
because i don't love you when you're fat
so i really appreciate that but yeah me
and uh mom bear
we were having a meeting on zoom
because we're meeting even in the same
room because we're all in the same
company but people are different places
and it was crazy the feedback so on one
hand i love having her back with me the
other hand
it is tougher when
it's here in an office especially when
you don't like your co-workers hey dude
freaking [ __ ]
i'm just kidding
that's just a good award i know that's a
good word it's a [ __ ] good is that
gonna be good i don't know ginger with
the let me see monster mash mother have
ponboo oh true made it ready it's good
it's the good stuff
yeah eating healthy new year knew me
like she was saying trying to lose a
little bit of this
which is really nice
it's literally the same you always
[ __ ] up trying to do well i was
trying to get strong and i got pretty
strong
i've been hitting 455 consistently for
four weeks straight now i'm like cool i
got a good base strength now i could
build on top of it now i'm gonna get a
little bit leaner just so i don't look
so
ridiculous
okay so it's been kind of
a crazy
but a normal day because our days are
pretty crazy so ty is back at school
which has been kind of nice but i do
miss him but not as much to be like be
here because mama got [ __ ] to do you
know what i mean
so um had a bunch of meetings
uh then it's lunch time as bart was
talking about we're eating our healthy
meals again
um as i was getting that done i ordered
groceries thank god for instacart
because i was able to get like milk and
i got um some bagels
yeah
if you guys are just eating regular
peanut butter without the honey
[Music]
what are you doing
stop it right now go get peanut butter
with honey in it it is a game changer
the same way crunchy
peanut butter is a game changer and if
you don't like crunchy peanut butter
we can still be friends but i mean i'm
gonna be like oh you like that sticky
mouth huh you like that roof [ __ ] oh how
about a roof type of stuff
but we'll still be friends
um i always have
frosting
and eggs on deck
because my little duty duty
loves baking he loves being in the
kitchen which is ironic because i don't
hate it
i just never i feel like i have i'll
explain why i did this in a minute but
i never had a reason to be in the
kitchen because growing up my mom always
cooked and then my grandma would bounce
back and forth between her daughter here
in california
or in california
aka my mom or mexico guadalajara jalisco
to be exact with her other daughter so
she would spend a few months there and
then a few months with us
in the time that she was with us
um
she would cook all the time and she
loved cooking and then when i would try
to learn she'd be like
like get out of this kitchen you don't
belong here and now i'm old and i'm like
i should have learned but because of
that i never had a reason to learn so i
didn't
so i don't really ever cook
but taika loves it so that's the irony
that i'm talking about um so yeah
i really try to nurture that so anytime
he wants to bake or cook i'm all about
it so i always try to have these things
on deck so that when he's ready we're
ready to rock and this bread right here
is just nostalgic my mom always got the
spread it's not the best it's not the
most flavorful it's not the softest it's
not the sweet like it's
very mediocre bread it's still bomb
though
don't get me wrong it's still bomb
but it's nothing special
but it's special to me
because my mom always had this bread
and it was just always in the house so
when i have it now it makes me think of
her and it makes me feel all soft and
warm and fuzzy on the inside so i got it
you know for that reason i got taika
some cereal because he loves cereal
some more cereal
got us some little snacks these are
awesome especially if you're cutting or
you're on a diet or if you're just not
on a diet and you want like a light
little snack these are great it's only
50 calories per cake um you can add
fruit yogurt you can mash it up i mean
these are just such a versatile and they
come in so many different
um oh it's gluten free too but so many
different flavors you can get them
savory you can get them sweet you get
them plain
um
i like to put peanut butter on them or i
just eat it like this with coffee
caramel is my favorite this brand
specifically is my favorite like it's i
think an off brand but it's the best in
this flavor and they have one in
chocolate that i could never find
anywhere anymore like i feel like
every time they restock it everyone
takes them off the shelves so i could
never find them
so i'm on the quest for those but for
now
caramel and i think apple cinnamon are
the [ __ ]
okay so now i was going like this was
because
at least one of us is on a diet clearly
i'm not so i ate one of these these are
so
[ __ ] bad so there's three of them
it's 12 grams of [ __ ] fat that is
horrible
two grams of protein this is the worst
macros ever
sorry for the weird angle but these are
the macros i want
one gram of protein even though that's
still very little but zero fat
you want your fats to be lower
but that's not a general rule of thumb
it all depends on what your fitness goal
is
it also depends on how your body
processes fats carbs um
the type of metabolism you have some
people have super fast metabolism some
people have very low slow metabolism so
people just have regular ass metabolism
so like anything i say or if anyone ever
tries to pitch it to you as this is law
this is it it is what it is
they're [ __ ] go the other direction
do not listen to them there's no general
rule of thumb for a lot of these things
other than
we should be eating fruits veggies
protein and even protein doesn't have to
be meat okay when i say protein there's
so many things that have protein in it
so you can have a vegan diet and still
get protein i mean your protein sources
are going to be completely different
because there's different minerals and
vitamins that animal protein has versus
like plant protein but that still can be
remedied with like micronutrients uh uh
uh supplements um
multivitamins like there's just so many
different things so my point is there's
no one rule of thumb
for anything in this life
so just do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do just keep it healthy you know what i
mean um
okay so as i was eating this food gets
dropped off which is awesome and then i
get a phone call about my car because my
lease is up
i leased my tesla for
three years and if you're wondering like
is it better to lease or finance another
rule of thumb that does not apply that
is not a general rule of thumb
is that
everyone is different
it depends on what your life structure
is it depends on where you want to be in
the next five ten years it depends on
where you want to be the one year um if
you're a business owner in the beginning
maybe even towards the middle like
there's no general rule this isn't this
annoying but like for most
uh business owners leasing is better
than financing but again there's no
general of them so
what did you learn today jack [ __ ]
you're welcome
but yeah so my lease was up
and usually i get another lease so
before this car i had a bmw before that
car i had my honda
before that car i had my first car ever
which is a geoprism
um i bought my geo financed my honda
lease my beemer and then this is the
second lease i've had so i was about to
lease again
but with all these supply chain
shortages and just
everything
like being so um
limited in supply
cars are so much more expensive and so
hard to come by
so i was just like i'm just gonna take
my lease over so i was talking to the
guy
about converting my lease into a finance
and
i think i own my tesla now which is
really cool
um so
thank you
i'm an adult now
i got you from school what did we just
pick up
snacks show me what snacks you bought i
got
i got rice krispies and an egg yeah why
do you get so many snacks
yummy so yummy
yeah so that's been our tradition we
either get dutch bros psycho get not
coffee obviously he'll get like this
strawberry slush but right now since
it's been cold it makes his throat cold
so then he starts coughing so the
alternative is just getting a little
snack before jiu-jitsu hot dude
yeah i can't open this i will open it
yeah he gets this guy have you guys had
this is like really
delicious can you hold it for mommy yes
mama you're holding it okay
you got it yes okay point it at mama
yeah okay so this is really cool is it
heavy
no oh wow here's a strong eye and then
we open it one side has what what does
one side have on the other side this
will have a toy this is a chocolate yeah
show me show everybody show everybody in
the world
so that one has the toy or does that
have the chocolate chocolate
you know i've never had these before you
did you know that
no thanks
it's like this hazelnut chocolate i'm
gonna open that too
this one's the top oh dude let me see it
oh here mama
oh i get the trash
thanks dude you're so nice
okay tell me what it tastes like
taste it taste it hurry
mmm
does it taste like
chocolate and vanilla and vanilla
let me see let me see
yum whoa that looks delicious
okay so while he does that this a lot of
um
vegas
uh gas stations they have a
drive-through
car wash and i haven't washed my car in
literally months
so we're gonna go through that and it's
really bad to go through it with a wrap
on but
yolo
look monkey the beginning
of the wash has begun
we haven't gone through it yet are you
ready dude whoa did you finish that
already
let me see
it only took me like five minutes to pay
dude
wow you're fast
cause i love it
i did avoid the hot wax and all that
stuff because again i have a wrap so
this is just to be a simple wash
you ready monkey monkey oh no
is it cool look at that guys
who are you talking to
the camera oh okay
is it cool
and i think that's it
yeah that looks cool it was cool
now it's gonna dry it
just gonna dry it yeah
big fan just gonna dry it all
yeah
it's because it's getting dry
yeah go
whoa that was really cool
really handsome oh thank you mama cut it
out
wow what is that doing to you is he
getting me moist
you're very handsome baby you're very
handsome
i just got back from my haircut and i
think i found my spot in vegas
and i went with the owner of the shop
this time and it came out
really good
what are you doing nothing stop making
fun of me
but check it out so that's the front
that's it absolutely it's the side
yeah that's what you wanted to do what
what what your soul and then look at
this
came out really good right
it did it i found my spot
found
on your barber yeah
and he's cool to talk to which is like
half the experience oh thank you very
much
so i find myself
at one of
the worst
hotels
or casinos actually in vegas we are at
circus circus
and for no other reason than to get
bomb ass steakhouse yes i said that
correctly there is a bomb steakhouse
called the steakhouse here and it is
highly rated the steak house is so bomb
i can't wait to show you what it looks
like on the inside because it's really
ghetto here but the steak house is
definitely not so let's go inside
hey
what up dude
what's up dude
man
i showed nick bucksack plus i showed
nick uh his uh sprawls yesterday they're
pretty good
they're pretty good let me see a little
sprawl
all right now he's gonna catch it on
this car he already has carpet probably
this carpet is it's super clean they
just played they're like he's just gone
hey let me see your sprawl dude
that's the right answer that's the right
answer i'm not your mother that's how
you get beat up dude
that's that take down that's like beat
up
so we're inside now and this is the part
that's a huge trip because outside you
see all those clowns and circus and that
being right
but all of a sudden you walk into the
steak house
and it's like this reminds me of a
restaurant that being like a mob movie
right like good fellas or casino because
allison has this vibe
like old school music playing
and then it has this hello
good and it just has like uh like you
know those lanterns
you know
it just has this like mafia vibe
and i have no idea where i'm at now i
just lost everyone this is where i trust
on
[Music]
oh yeah
he's kind of lame he went back you know
he's coming he's here he's here oh
he's meeting up with a friend or
something no he's uh dropping off his
girl at the airport oh and then meeting
with the friend you're right
all right so we got what new york rip
eye fellaini on all this but look at
this menu mafia style once again
oh funky boy hello how's everyone doing
tonight good how are you doing good
welcome to the steakhouse my name is
yeah i always hated suits
oh
i feel like i made a mistake or
something mistake on a steak
[Applause]
come on
i'll give you my turn
crunchy on the outside oh
[Music]
you said bump it i was not imagining
this this is like nick's trying to learn
right of me
but yeah
so what if my hands that is dope dude
dude check out the shower bro come here
wow
dude
his and her sinks i'll be the herd are
his and his zigs
that's the biggest mouth i've ever seen
now what you have that for what were you
about to to get some more work done yeah
what do you have your fans
out the bottom of your sweater i'm cold
cutie
that's me
yeah we're both tired
this house feels very cuny with our
friends coming to visit and stay here
they're actually out here because we're
shooting some uh
jk new stuff
so
it feels cuny to have them in here and
everyone's just a bunch of goofballs
but i'm gonna go to sleep now and i'll
see you guys tomorrow good night